>>Derek: The high school was
underperforming according
to the State's measures.
We were the fifth lowest performing
high school in New Hampshire.
>>Student: A con is some
students will not be happy
that their freedom will be taken away.
>>Derek: We wanted our
students to take more ownership
for the operation of the school.
>>Student: A pro would
be that the grades
that they're expecting is reasonable.
>>Derek: And so we began to
develop plans for a Site Council
to increase student engagement.
>>Tucker: Anybody got
anything else they want to add,
pro, con?
>>Tucker: At this time,
I can entertain a motion.
All in favor.
>>Derek: Student voice was a key part
of rethinking what equity
among our students looked like.
And how they may have control.
We bring together this group of
key stakeholders to be a part
in that decision-making process.
>>Teacher: There's going
to be a limit on the amount
of credits that could be earned.
>>Derek: Including the
overall course grade.
>>Derek: Surveys have
been sent out via email.
>>Teacher: I don't really
care about that part as much.
>>Tucker: Site Council is the
governing body of the school.
We're responsible for making any
changes to do with student procedures,
policies that aren't governed
by State or Schoolboard law.
>>Derek: Site Council's made decisions
regarding the dress code, open campus,
grades and grading policy,
the class schedule.
>>Derek: You know, with somebody,
I'll do the pros list if one
of the students wants to do
the cons, I'm happy to help.
>>Teacher: If you don't have
a passing grade in the class,
should you be allowed open campus,
was the question we were-- ?
>>Colby: We went over the current policy
using feedback that we came up with.
>>Teacher: We put out
a form for some data.
>>Colby: In such a small environment
like this, actually having a voice,
and getting opinions from
everyone in the school,
it's pretty cool to be a part of that.
>>Derek: What was the student consensus?
>>Colby: The students that
I talked to would agree
that course grading would be-- should
be-- and hopefully will be a factor.
>>Savannah: Most students in the
class, they have very loud opinions,
but they won't tend to share
it with the rest of the school.
>>Savannah: Students have to be passing
their classes with a 2.5 or higher.
I think that could be
factored in as well.
>>Tucker: I think that's a great idea.
>>Savannah: So I figured that
the students could come to me,
so I can get their opinion.
And when I vote it's
not just my opinion.
It's my entire class'.
>>Colby: Especially when
they start taking--
>>Student: All of your
overall classes of the 2.5.
>>Derek: Through the discussions
that we're able to have here,
we not only identified that
there needed to be a change,
but the Council really was the
voice for making that change.
>>Colby: At Site Council, me and
Miss Massey brought up a Proposal--
>>Tucker: After we make the
decision with the Council,
we go back to class meetings.
Definitely seems to work and
get information out pretty well.
>>Student: Will this go into effect
next year, or is it happening this year?
>>Tucker: I like being able to work
with teachers, work with peers.
>>Colby: Any other questions?
>>Tucker: It's just easy to voice
input and have somebody listen.
>>Student: Kind of rewards
the people who really did
that extra mile to try hard.
>>Tucker: Yep.